[Musique]
qu'est ce que tu sais de les sauveurs
wallace et de son meurtre biggie et
tenté de découvrir qui a vraiment tué
notorious big screen
voilà la ligne dans une nouvelle équipe
de travail c'est une affaire classée
je veux que tu rejoignes moi c'est quoi
la faire et gamers
ça va bientôt faire dix ans la division
de la crim enquêter là-dessus dirigé par
russell poule mais je promets que ce
département fera tout ce qui est en son
pouvoir pour découvrir qui a tué votre
fils la plupart des témoins de la scène
à qui on a parlé étaient soit très peu
coopératif soit il souffrait
soudainement de pertes de mémoire pour
ça avait commencé dans les rues voletta
wallace est convaincu que la police de
los angeles aurait joué un rôle majeur
dans le meurtre de son pic il y a une
grande probabilité que le meurtre de
biggie smalls soit directement liées au
meurtre de tupac
on parle de mes dix mots cette affaire
c'est juste légendaire et ça va faire
dix ans tu veux vraiment être le flic
qui réussira à résoudre le mystère
tu veux accuser des officiers de police
de l'est l'a peut-être conspiré dans
l'assassinât d'une célébrité noir
un truc de conspiration la cette
histoire tu en penses quoi
or quel camp tu es je suis dans le camp
qui veut ré ou telle affaire big y avait
24 ans goût de l'effort tout pas quand
même et 25
c'étaient encore des gamins